coach Smith what a pillar for not just
college basketball but for sports and
his his legacy is not Championships
obviously he wanted a bunch of
Championships and a bunch of games but I
believe his legacy is is the men that he
produced and if you talk to any one of
his players to a man they'll tell you
that they're better fathers was about
our husbands they're better people
because of Coach Smith and I had the
great opportunity to to be recruited by
him before he retired and I'll never
forget the day that I I committed to
Duke University and I had to call coach
Smith and tell him that I am going to
his archrival and so I'm all nervous and
I said coach you know I have so much
respect for you and your program that no
I would've had a fantastic career at
University of North Carolina but
unfortunately I'm I've decided to go to
Duke University and I'm sitting there on
oh no what he's gonna be bitter and he
said you know Shane you're one of the
classiest young men I've ever had a
chance to recruit I'll be cheering for
you except when we played Duke and
you're gonna do fantastic and no and he
followed that up with a fantastic
handwritten note to my parents and a
fantastic handwritten note to me that I
still have in my house and it just sums
up the class of the man and he was he
was a giant and he'll be missed
you